bienvenidos a esta segunda parte de los
vídeos de notación de unidades de
vectores aunque ya han pasado varios
meses desde el primer vídeo de unidades
vectoriales que desarrollé en este
segundo vídeo vamos a retomar un poco
estos lados el uso de que nos sirve la
anotación vectorial las ventajas que
tiene
en el vídeo anterior de unidad notación
de unidades vectoriales o de vectores
les dije que si tenía dos vectores por
ejemplo mi vector a que era igual a
menos tres y
más
j
recordamos que y es la dirección de un
vector con unidad 1 que va si es
positivo va hacia arriba si es negativo
va hacia abajo y el vector j si es
positivo va a la derecha y si es
negativo va a la izquierda
entonces tengo este vector y además
tengo otro vector
qué es
y ve tiene los valores 2 y
+ 4 j entonces la ventaja o una de las
ventajas de esta anotación vectorial es
que podemos hacer la suma de vectores
sin tener que graficar los y de hecho es
mucho más fácil hacerlo así entonces si
yo quiero a sumar
mis vectores voy a ponerla en otro color
para que se note un poco mejor
la suma de mis vectores
ah
más ni vectores
d
es igual
a la suma de los elementos o de los
términos que son del vector
esto es con el vector y más
la suma de los términos que tienen el
vector j
entonces en este caso es menos 3
+ 2
y
en este caso es dos más
j
así que bueno nada más hago esta
operación en este caso
me suma a mis vectores
director resultante va a ser igual a
menos tres más dos igual a uno y que
puedo incluso dejarlo así con el vector
i
más
y esta es la suma de mis dos vectores
como ven pues es bastante sencillo y
bastante directo aunque ustedes quizás
me digan que pues no pueden creer
ciegamente en que esto ocurre sí solo
porque yo se los digo lo cual es una
opinión muy válida así que les mostraré
que esto funciona al hacer la suma de
vectores gráficamente
ahora lo que voy a hacer es graficar
mi eje
de las equis y ustedes disculparán que
no esté perfectamente
alineado lo estoy haciendo a mano alzada
tengo aquí mi eje de la sien o mi eje en
este caso del vector j
y aquí es el vector
entonces vamos a graficar el
el vector
vamos a usar un poco las coordenadas
vamos a hacer a dividir aquí
así que no va a quedar muy a escala
porque como les digo lo estoy haciendo
pues a mano alzada sin ningún elemento
de medición más preciso para hacer estás
divisiones en los ejes
pero bueno esperemos que quede lo
suficientemente claro para que ustedes
comprenden la explicación
de que podemos usar la notación
vectorial de la misma manera y de hecho
es mucho más sencilla y nos da los
mismos resultados que hacer la suma de
vectores gráficamente
entonces mi vector a tiene menos tres
elementos en y
voy a dibujarlos con diferentes colores
entonces es menos 1 - 2 - 3
más o menos en la dimensión y aquí llega
mi vector en esta parte y más 2 j
+ 2 j más o menos
aquí entonces bueno si recuerdan la suma
de vectores si tenemos un vector
y donde termina uno inicia el otro los
vectores mientras tengan la misma
dirección y la magnitud no importa donde
los gráficos van a ser los mismos
entonces mi vector va a ser desde el
inicio de este desde el primer actor
hasta dónde termina el segundo vector y
este es mi vector
vamos a hacer lo mismo con mi vector b
en este caso en las dimensiones de es 2
y llega más o menos sacar
j es 4 j vamos a usar otro color un poco
diferente
1 2 3 4
hasta acá llega
acción note que están los dos hasta aquí
llega en la componente vertical de mi
vector b
entonces bueno lo voy a trasladar este
vector a donde termina este otro
elemento para hacer la suma de mis dos
vectores
y este es bueno no sé
estas son los componentes ahora voy a
hacer la suma uniendo el
inicio del primer vector con el final
del segundo vector algo más o menos así
y este es mi vector b y para sumar
además b lo que voy es trasladar este
vector
ven más o menos
al final de mi vector
más o menos quedaría algo así aunque
como les digo no va a quedar tan preciso
este es mi vector b
aproximadamente
y mi vector además ve
si yo 1 este es el inicio de mi lectora
con el final de mi vector b que dibuje
acá entonces me va a quedar
algo así
este es
más ve que pueden verlas con de
coordenadas son 1 2 3 4 5 6 y aquí más o
menos -1 lo que nos da los mismos
elementos
pero de una manera
digamos que la gráfica pues necesitamos
hacer más elementos y los dibujos tienen
que ser más precisos d en cambio si
usamos la notación vectorial pues bueno
podemos hacer la suma directamente
también la ventaja es que si yo tengo
cantidades muy grandes en y en j pues mi
gráfica va a ser tremendamente compleja
en cambio aquí no importa qué cantidad
sea pues bueno voy a poder hacer las
operaciones mucho más fácilmente porque
sólo voy a estar sumando o manejando
estas cantidades con respecto a iu y con
respecto a j
ahora vamos a poder resolver problemas
como los de movimientos de proyectiles
mucho más fácilmente y además vamos a
poder hacer otras cosas usando esta
anotación vectorial